Alex Jones ordered to pay 965 million
dollars for Sandy Hook lies an hour ago
I I saw that and I just burst it out
laughing I think I was on the toilet and
I'm like I'm looking at my phone and I'm
like like right when the news breaks I
was like is this a joke come on you know
when they did the 50 million dollars I
was like wow that's brutal they're still
I still doubt anyone's gonna get a penny
from this because the way lawsuits work
Alex Jones says he doesn't even have the
money anyway then they they're a billion
this is this is just like what is this
for narrative and for the TV to say oh
you know he lied about this and now he's
got to pay one billion dollars it
reminds me of uh Austin Powers when uh
in the first one he freezes himself and
then he goes to the Future and he says I
want one million dollars and they all
laugh at him and then they're like uh Dr
Evil one million dollars today isn't
actually a lot of money and he's like oh
and then in the next one he goes back in
time and says I want a hundred billion
dollars and I'll start laughing at me
again saying you might as well have just
said a bajillion gajillion dollars that
money doesn't exist